(audience applauds)
It is time for Drew's News.
Your cozy little good news cat
taking a warm nap in your lap.
(audience laughs)
Um, so, Rossy?
Yes.
Rossy Ross Matthews, everybody.
Oh, well, hi, everybody, hi.
(audience applauds)
Hi, Drew.
Love you.
I Love you.
There is big news out there today.
Are we gonna hit it?
Oh, let's,
Let's hit it hard.
Did you guys hear this one?
Ben and Jen getting,
they're getting married, what?
(audience applauds)
They're engaged again!
People reports, Jennifer Lopez is sporting
a green engagement ring from Ben Affleck.
Her sister, Linda shared a pic on Instagram
with a huge congratulations that went super viral ASAP.
Yeah.
And Jennifer says green is a lucky color for her.
I mean, it certainly is.
She's wore that Versace dress.
We all remember that.
Oh, I remember that.
She has a big piece of Barbara Kruger art
that has like green hummingbirds.
She's actually like, the green is a good color
for an important, meaningful, significant one.
Yeah, well this is significant
and I'm obsessed with this.
I've always been fascinated by people who break up
and then years later, get back together.
Am I the only one that's fascinated by that, you guys?
No.
No, because-
(audience applauds)
Raise your hand if you're into-
Yes.
Second chances.
Yes, heat up those leftovers, honey, get 'em.
(Drew laughs)
They're still good.
Never looked at it that way.
I do, that's all I think about.
And I think too,
was she pining this whole time thinking about him?
Did she watch "Gone Girl" and be like,
"Ooh, why you gone, girl?"
(Drew laughs)
(audience laughs)
Have you ever thought about
getting back together with an ex?
Oh God yes.
Really?
I've tried so many times.
And?
Um, well,
you know, it's funny,
'cause I always beat myself up,
and I was like, "I am the problem.
I am the common denominator of all the breakups."
Mm-hm?
And then a few I've revisited
and I'm like, "Okay,
the problems I had, I have overcome and fixed
and you're still in the same place.
That's very interesting."
So it was kind of a nice, helpful thing for me,
where I was like,
"I don't need all the blame for this not working."
Yeah, it is fascinating because I think relationships
are as much about timing as they are about the individual.
Yeah.
Right?
Don't you guys agree?
So maybe this is their time.
(audience applauds)
I hope so.
Also, I think we revisit because we loved them.
Yeah.
And they made us laugh
or there was something about them.
And those things, you know,
I've always had that sort of profound question,
when you break up, where does the love go?
Mm.
And I think this is very hopeful
for all the people who are romantics out there.
Yes, and we do love love around here.
We do!
(bright music)